since i'm talking about pictures today
i went down a bit of a rabbit hole you
know the kind you do when you get on
wikipedia and you start clicking you
know
eventually end up at philosophy
but i want to share a few just kind of
for interest sake
so this picture here on the left
these are some cave paintings like it's
one of the earliest known images ever
found
is in
bonobos caves in southern africa it's
about 70 thousand years old uh that
second one i'm going to try and
pronounce it because i'll just embarrass
myself it's uh it's the first commercial
available camera that was so the public
could buy from 1839 and that third one
is a digital the first digital camera
ever made and it took 16 batteries to
power if you can imagine that
so and also if i can address the
elephant in the room
this is in fact another talk on krypto
steganography
i know you're probably all sick of them
by now but uh yeah seriously
um if i can actually be serious for a
moment
um this is more of a
talk where the story is stranger than
fiction
and some text sprinkled in and i was
kind of thinking given the state of the
world right now what kind of talk
i'd like to hear and so i'm hoping
you're all you'd all feel the same way
so if you're interested in hearing an
entertaining story you're definitely in
the right place
but if that doesn't sound like something
you're interested in i'll take no
offense if you want to get up and leave
okay you have no one to blame but
yourself
so hey i'm sean
i'm going to be chatting today about
crypto stegonography anomaly anyway uh
less this is less code heavily than a
lot of the strange loops talks but um
most ages have an interesting story i
want to share
and also during my talk
feel free to break out into laughter and
uncontrollable applause i've built that
into the timing of the talk
[Applause]
yes
so to introduce myself here's four fun
facts about me uh i'm originally from
canada
uh like all canadians i enjoy lovingly
trolling people uh about one in four
people seem to appreciate my sense of
humor
and if you have heard of me before it's
probably because of ruby for good
which is a non-profit i created that
builds and maintain software for other
non-profits i think animal shelters food
banks women's shelters
basically kind of places that are
desperate for folks of our skill sets
but would never be able to afford us
and we also find we also provide a way
for companies to do meaningful skills
based volunteering so if your company is
looking for a way for
you all to volunteer get in touch so
that's my pitch to come do good
and as someone who recently put on a
conference
last weekend
but definitely not this scale
i can't even begin to imagine you know
the amount of stress and you know
putting on a conference of this
magnitude especially you know given the
delta variant raging and so if you do
see an organizer
uh or if you don't see one go find one
and hug them well probably don't hug
them unless you brought a hazmat suit
but definitely say thank you
and i do want to take a minute to
acknowledge kovid because seriously
wow like this is a bonkers world we're
living in and i hope everyone is taking
time to practice self-care and taking
care of themselves especially now
and i hear from a lot of people right
now that
like the root of all the bad things
happening are you know boiled down to
politics
and
i do want to
make a quick digression into that
because i don't think
i know i have a hard time buying it
and you know because i think like the
rest of you like what was it five or six
years ago when there was an election and
the new guy was elected
and like this guy who i thought was like
like wow i like this guy he he gets me
he i'm proud of him i'm proud the way he
represents me on a world stage you know
especially given how absolutely terrible
the guy before him was
and so if i can take a minute i do want
to congratulate
trudeau on winning re-election
and
i i hope that canada continues to lead
the way in terms of vaccination rates
but jokes aside
the pandemic has messed with my sense of
time
probably the world sense of time because
i don't understand why the olympics had
happened this past summer were there
still the 2020 olympics
um
[Music]
to be fair though i don't think i could
swear under oath that they happened in
2021
but hopefully everyone was able to watch
them because it was nice even you know
despite the empty stadiums it was nice
to see the world come together
and it was even nicer to see a fellow
canadian trolling one of their teachers
and i think i mentioned canadians like
to love lee troll
um and penny is awesome uh you should
definitely follow her on social media
and i love to watch swimming in the
olympics like especially when you could
walk watch an athlete like penny
one of those uh once in a generation
athletes you know like michael phelps or
michael jordan like someone who really
like elevates a sport to the next level
and as much as like watching
swimming my favorite sport to watch by
far
is curling
and if you've never had the opportunity
to watch it played
curling's an amazing sport
you know requires teamwork
strategy skill
and enjoyment of being out on the ice
and in the cold
and i love all those things
but none of those are why i truly love
the sport like the real reason i like
curling
is that when i watch curling on tv
i legitimately think i could compete in
the olympics
[Music]
like look at this guy
he's a freak i'm never going to be like
him
well maybe i'll eat 11 000 calories in a
day but i'm not gonna be this guy
but this guy
he's one of he's won multiple olympic
medals
you know including gold and that's kevin
martin he's a canadian curler
and he inspires me
and so another reason i like curling is
because my dogs really like to watch
girling with me
and these are my dogs by the way that's
roadie and taffy
and when i rescued my dogs i was only
planning on getting one dog but you know
they insisted they go together because
they were you know a bonded pair
and i just thought that was a scam to
get people to you know adopt more dogs
but it turns out you know they really
were you know bonded and you know i'm
super smitten with them both now and i
can't imagine my life without either of
them
see they are bonded
and um
you know the the bigger dog taffy who's
very food motivated
uh who actually answers to the name
piggy uh you know she came up to my desk
a few days ago and she came up and she
was crying and so i assumed she was
hungry and fed her some treats and
she should cry more fed her more treats
she cried even more so i fed her even
more treats she wouldn't quit crying so
i thought i had to feed her dinner and i
took her downstairs and
it turned out that um the 12 samosas i
thought for dinner she'd eaten nine of
them and that was enough for four people
so i knew why she was crying
but you know the funny thing is about
these pictures is that when i'm this is
the kind of pictures i show to people
when they ask about my dogs
but you know they're not usually like
this like you know
for lack of a better word they're
usually little weirdos
and the thing is it's not just dogs that
are weirdos
like people can be weirdos too and you
know and speaking of weirdos
a while ago uh you know i opened up my
email and i had an email from a weird
friend
a weirdo if you will
and so like there was nothing in the
email there was no subject line no body
just this picture
and uh this that's buffy the vampire
slayer uh if you're not familiar with a
tv show in the 90s and early 2000s
and
i really like the show probably more
than the next person but again the guy's
a little weird so i didn't think
anything of the picture just deleted it
and went on
but then a few days later
you know this photo showed up in my
my inbox
[Music]
and uh yes
um
and again like this is uh from babylon
five probably the best science fiction
series uh ever made and i'm happy to
argue with anyone i'd accept maybe the
expanse but uh you know if you account
for time i uh i still think it's about
one five uh and did everyone hear that j
michael straczynski is uh rebooting the
series
yes
i know isn't that awesome uh i'm excited
but again you know like nothing in the
body nothing in the subject line so i
deleted the image
and then you know a few days later this
picture shows up in my inbox
and this is this is from a firefly again
a tv stitch series from the early 2000s
and then you know again deleted it
because there was no subject no body
just thought the friend was weird but
then he started repeating the pictures
you know sometimes three in one day
sometimes
you know a couple days would go between
him a week
and so i was a little curious so you
know i texted him i emailed him
you know and then i finally did that
thing that every one of us absolutely
hates to do
yeah i called him on the phone
and you know to his credit he answered
and
but then he just pretended like he had
no idea what i was talking about and as
someone who likes to troll i appreciated
that
so
i called up a mutual friend and asked
him what was up with mike
actually since i'm being recorded i
probably shouldn't use real names uh
i called up a mutual friend and asked
what was up with uh brad
and um
and he uh he did some digging and he
came back with the cryptic comment with
everything you need to know is in the
pictures
and um
i'm obviously a big fan of all these
shows
and uh if you're a fan of these shows
too come find me after we could probably
be friends um
and so my first idea had something to do
maybe what was in the pictures or what
was in the episodes
um and you know i was wasn't finding
anything you know i even jumped onto
imdb looking for connections between
like the writers of the story like no
idea what's going on and i even thought
oh maybe that episode you know where
years waving uh to mr morton's head oh
maybe it was the episode where he made
the threat to mr morton and you know i
was coming up with so many theories you
know i rewatched all the firefly
episodes no
you know because firefly um
you know but you know at the end of the
day all i was coming up with theories
and nothing uh
nothing
concrete
and i think
you know due to the fact that i was
actually trying and like the mutual
friend was also you know he'd become
kind of interested in what was happening
uh mike
uh brad became more communicative and
i think it was mostly because he uh
uh you know he wanted he thought he'd
done something clever and he wanted us
to you know know what it was
and so uh
oh i should probably let everyone know
how i
how i know brad
so back in 2003 i got a call out of the
blue from that mutual friend i mentioned
and he said something like like hey sean
you're from canada are you not a girl do
you wanna do you wanna fill in for
someone on our team tonight for our
match
and you know my first thought was to get
mad
and uh
and you know say something like hey you
shouldn't stereotype me and you know
assume that i love maple syrup i know
how to curl you know i'm handsome i'm
charming i'm funny you know just because
i'm from canada
you know but then i thought well you
know these stereotypes do exist for a
reason
and because i do like maple syrup and
actually i do know how to curl but you
know i told them i hadn't curled in like
six years or so but i'd be happy to you
know come out and help
and so
i don't want to say i'm a hero because i
feel like that word gets overused
but you know i won or we we won
um
but you know more importantly i was able
to like really help coach and like give
a lot of guidance to the other people on
the team and they were so happy that
they asked me to become a permanent
member because the person i was filling
in for like actually wasn't interested
anymore
and was happy
everyone's happy it was a good situation
but i should also point out that the
person i replaced was brad
and so we're all happy at least for a
while
and but something might surprise people
here
is that competing in sports
is more fun when you're winning or at
least you're competitive like it's a lot
more fun than going and getting
destroyed week after week after week
and um
and like who knew
but like now that we're we were doing
well
and uh you know it was exciting and
because we're all having fun it often
became like a topic of conversation when
we're out with friends and we're sitting
at the bar and with our partners and i
think our partners and friends really
hated it because that's all we would
talk about
um
but you know after about a year of this
uh brad offered to rejoin the team but
you know the team was full and we're all
having fun so there was no room
[Music]
and something else i did during this
time is i inspired everyone else in the
group
i think inspired as the correct way to
stay bullied
into becoming curling fans when the
winter olympics was on
and we'd all get together we'd watch
curling in the olympics and um and if i
guess we couldn't get together we'd
watch and watch from home and message
each other online
and uh you know looking at me you
probably assume that since i like to
troll that
when my team's winning i'm very humble
and a gracious winner
but that wasn't always the case and
uh younger sean was a little less
evolved
and kind of for reference
this is what happened in the first three
olympics we watched
you know
canada canada
canada
and so like in the months leading up to
the 2018 olympics you can probably
imagine maybe it was a little bit smug
and had a certain attitude on what was
going to happen and that's also
coincidentally when the photos started
showing up in my inbox
so anyways back to the pictures
so brad let me know that it actually
wasn't the exact pictures that mattered
it was something that was inside the
pictures
and so like now i knew that you know he
had embedded something in them
and so my first thought was he created
one of those like magic eye images
i know is everyone familiar with the
magic eye picture
it's one of those pictures where like
you just stare at it and you let your
eyes go uh
distant and you can see an image in
there
this image actually contains a forest if
anyone can
see it
and so i you know i connected my tv up
to my uh my laptop and you know blew the
pictures up really big and stared at
them
for way too long way way way too long uh
they weren't magic eye pictures
and so i was able after i was able to
determine they weren't magic eye images
i probably did what i should have done
in the first place
you know i contacted the arbiter of all
knowledge
google and asked it about embedding
information in images
and the first result was all about
cryptos dengonography
giant waste time
so cryptostagrenography if you're not
familiar comes from the greek roots of
crypto
from the greek for melting the ice
sheets and destroying the environment
and steganography which is a kind of
dinosaur
uh steganography is actually the
practice of hiding information in plain
sight
like something that's uh not secret
you just have to know it's there and
this is the concept that goes back and
we have recorded usage going back over
2500 years and like these are wax
tablets
the ancient greeks romans and whatnot
use them they were a precursor to like
chalkboards and whiteboards
so you could write on the wax and then
smooth it over and right on the wax
again
so back when peugeot was planning on
invading greece in 440 bc
the greeks in persia they would burn
messages onto the wax boards cover them
with wax and then send them back and so
you just have to knew the messages were
there you'd melt the wax and you could
read them
the other thing they did was they uh
they would shave the heads of slaves
they would tattoo a message into the
slaves heads
let their hair grow back and send them
to greece
so
i don't suggest
googling for images
to this because you're just going to go
down a really weird rabbit hole but i
did find this guy who apparently really
likes static website generators
i assume
and again you know segrenography
uh as time evolved time went on the
process kept evolving like starting in
about 1400 we have we have evidence of
uh
like documented use of people using
invisible ink and as kids we probably
all did experiments where we you know
write on lemon juice on paper and give
it to our friend and they'd heat it up
in front of a light bulb to get the
message
and uh
i highly recommend everyone coming to
washington dc to come to the spy museum
if you've never been
and if you come to washington dc let me
know i'm happy to take you out for a
coffee or tea or beer or whatever your
beverage of choice is but like there's a
lot of really cool examples where like
they would just
embed things into everyday items like
this rug is morris code and so there's a
message there and like individual like
bumps in the yarn would spell out
messages like really fascinating things
and you know in world war one like
like soldiers would underneath a stamp
they would send letters home and these
are actual
uh
uh world war one letters uh they would
send letters home but sometimes they
wouldn't want their families to see the
message and only their
you know they wouldn't want their wife
to see it they would want their
their lover to see it and so they'll
never know to take the stamp off or you
know um
they would send secret things to that
maybe they didn't want the army to know
about but like really really neat and um
and even too as as technology got better
there were micro dots and where like
just a tiny little period or a full stop
in a sentence if you zoom in on it you
know there's a whole bunch of
information
but i think everyone can probably see
what the big weaknesses in
steganography is uh you know it's
security by obscurity you know it relies
on people not discovering that the
message is right there in plain sight or
you know there's a dog hiding in the
teddy bears
and so you like if that wax board gets
left next to a stove the wax is going to
melt messages can be revealed or that if
that slave's hair line recedes or he
gets a haircut it's going to be really
obvious
which is where which is where
cryptography comes in you know even
starting back as far as ancient rome uh
you know caesar messages were encrypted
usually with a cipher with one of the
early ciphers being you know the caesar
cipher
and now we have like computers with you
know digital images and audio files
documents like all sorts of places where
we can hide and embed information
and i'm not going to go super deep into
this just because um
we're talking about some images
and uh but like i will say like this is
often done with really like nefarious
results like
in the past few years like a lot of the
big ransomware attacks have come because
of embedded information and it's often
an attack vector for these different
like trojans and viruses and whatnot
but you know the good news is is the
technology to detect uh embedded
information is equally sophisticated so
um
so there's that
uh but like as if you are interested in
sending encrypted information and you're
trying to think of a good way uh
researchers at cambridge have said to
send the information in a stream that
appears random
and i know like there's no such thing as
random information just get as close as
you can and i was trying to think what
would be uh
what i could use as a random stream of
information and this is what i came up
with
[Music]
sales seem to come in random order
so but back to the images and how
stegonography works with images so when
you're embedding images into uh text and
or when you're writing text into an
image
you want to alter the least significant
bit of the pixels and if you want to
embed an image inside of another image
you generally want to
alter the two least significant bits
and i know i just threw some new terms
at you pixels least significant bits and
i'll break those down
so
pixels
uh pixels are like the foundation of
every image
and so like if you zoom in on any image
far enough you'll see that it's made up
of millions and millions or thousands
and thousands of tiny little points of
color and those are pixels
and like we see her zoom in on her eye
and finally it's individual colors and
you put them all together you get an
image
and these these pixels are made up of
red green and blue and if you've ever
opened up a color picker on on your
computer or you've done css you've
probably seen
you know rgb
and
here's an example and hopefully this
isn't too small but you can see i just
picked a random green and you know we
have an rgb and it's a combination of a
red a green and a blue
and like i said if you've done css you
know that you can set that from 0 to
255.
and if you're wondering why these colors
go from 0 to 255
it's a binary
and binary is how computers ultimately
store all its information
you know all those little zeros and ones
in the matrix that's binary
and so you know with computers at their
core you know they represent everything
as a zero and a one
and those zeros and ones are bits and we
group bits into groups of eight which is
a byte
and you probably hear the term pipe and
a thousand or one
a thousand and twenty four bytes is a
kilobyte a thousand and twenty four
kilobytes it's a megabyte 1024 megabytes
it's a gigabyte and you keep getting
scaling like that up until you're
finally at google scale
and so if you're buying a laptop and it
has 128 gigs 28 gigabyte hard drive and
38 32 gigabytes of ram you know exactly
how many zeros and ones are in the ram
and are in the hard drive for you to
store information
and so like i said a byte has eight bits
that you can turn on or off
and an
if a bit is on it's represented with a
one if it's off it's a zero
and when we have a byte we start on the
right and uh
the value of each proceeding or each bit
to the left of it is doubled and so we
can see that here so like
here's just a random bite and so the the
value of the the right most bite is
valued at one then a two four if if it
were turned on all the way up to 128 and
so to get the value of this this byte
we're just going to add up those
those uh those values
and the value of this byte is 155.
nice
and here's just
some more examples if uh doing some
bite math bit math
and so like we see here like 10 is the
the eight bit is turned on and the two
bit is turned on
eight plus two is ten twenty is the
sixteen bit and the four bit 16 plus 4
is 20. if all the bits are turned on
it's 255.
and so hopefully that makes the rgb
color picker a little bit more make it
make a little bit more sense
and as we have 256 different
possibilities for each color that's
where the that
16 million possible color 60 million
plus possible colors come in you know
256 times 256 266 is 16 million 17
or hundred thousand um
yeah
and so if you're paying attention you
probably heard me say that you know we
wanna alter the least significant bit to
get the um
to you know embed information
and so
the least significant bits are the bits
on the right like because those those
bits change the value of the byte the
least so like you know the rightmost bit
only changes the value of a byte by one
but like the leftmost bit is going to
change it by 128.
and so like and especially with a css
color kind of thing like a 255 is going
to be in imperceptibly different than a
254.
and i'll show this
so like here here's a blue where all the
blue bits are turned on all the red bits
are turned off and all the green bits
are turned off and this is pure blue
but if we just change one bit like this
is the like this is imperceptible to the
human eye
and
two bits same thing you know one red bit
turned on one blue it turned off
three bits changed
and just to show them all together
so there's an imperceptible difference
but we've changed uh three bits here
and even just kind of for emphasis here
i did one where i changed the two least
significant bits of uh each of the
colors
and there should be no perceptible
difference to the human eye
and it's not just because like blue is a
primarily like rgb color like if we take
a mixed color like yellow again like
changing one two three bits there's no
difference
and so like that's that's how we embed
information into
uh an image so if we
so we take the last uh bit or so we take
the last uh yeah bit of every pixel so
we go through pixel by pixel grab the
last bit and so basically we're saying
we don't care what the last bit is we're
going to change this and so pixel by
pixel by pixel and
and then we put them into groups of
eight
all the way through embedding our
information and then
someone else then comes comes by and
grabs those pixels pulls them all out
grabs all those last pixels and grabs
all those zeros and ones puts them into
groups of eight throws them into ascii
and you know the 255 grabs the character
then the number of the letter and we
have our message
so
let's get back to those pictures
because you know hopefully everyone here
is starting to see where the story is
going
and remember
i'm telling you this because i had some
pictures that i knew contained
information
and again these are the pictures
so you know recapping here
so i have a friend i replaced on the
curling team
you know then i got a group of friends
really excited about curling
and we'd all watch olympic curling
together
and then when canada would invariably
win you know every
olympics was a less than gracious winner
i'm big enough to say that
maybe a bit of a troll leading up to the
olympics
and then shortly before the 2018
olympics i started getting some random
pictures in my email every few days
but then after the olympics i started
getting that same set of images multiple
times a day like every day for a few
weeks
and i think everyone here knows what
happened in the 2018 olympics
we're all curling fans but maybe
everyone was on a peace corps mission or
something and weren't able to tune in so
what happened was uh
the usa won gold
and uh
i guess that's kind of cool um
but you know i wish my friends would
have listened to me in 2018 that we
should stop caring about the men's
curling
and we should really focus on like the
newly introduced in 2018 mixed doubles
curling because it was brand new that
year
you know for gender equality that's the
one we should care about because you
know coincidentally you know canada won
gold in that
[Music]
so again enough digressions uh
i think everyone wants to know what was
in the messages that's probably the
reason y'all haven't left yet
uh and before i get to that i want to i
want to tell the story of the time i
met the canadian band the bare naked
ladies
no okay
ask me about that later
okay so i had these these skills
but actually you know when i started
decoding the messages it turns out that
the messages before the olympics
are the pictures before the olympics
contain different messages
than the pictures after the olympics
and um i can't repeat actually what was
in the messages leading up to the
olympics because i'm being recorded
but the
the gist of it is and the first
image
uh contained very disparaging comments
about canada the second one contained
very disparaging comments on my curling
ability
and the third one talked about how this
was america's year to win gold at
curling
so the messages that came after the
olympics though was just the same
message over and over and over and over
again that message was
and you know if you were paying
attention that was the score by which uh
the u.s won gold that year
[Music]
so
so they say you know if you tell a story
it's really important for the
protagonist to show growth and character
development
and so i want to share
what the moral is and what i've learned
and the takeaways that i hope you can
all apply to your lives
so i've reflected done soul searching
and i thought long and hard about it
and this is what i've come up with
so the canadian curling team was
sabotaged in the 2018 olympics
so the world curling illuminati
conspired to let the usa win
my leaking my speaking out here is going
to lead to me being silenced so i
encourage you all to spread the word far
and wide
i hope you enjoyed the story maybe
learned something thanks for your time
[Music]
you